Speaker 1: Donald Trump was so triggered by Chris
Christie's town hall during which Chris Christie
attacked Trump on issues, on facts, on deficit,
on Ukraine. Right. Like not doing the anti-woke
stuff. Trump was so triggered. That he went after
Chris Christie because Chris Christie is obese,
but Trump is obese. And this is quite a double
standard that I want to talk about. Donald Trump
posting to his platform Truth social.
Speaker 4: Essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. How many times did Chris
Christie use the word small? Does he have a
psychological problem with size? Actually, his
speech was small and not very good. It rambled
all over the place and nobody had a clue of what
he was talking about. Hard to watch. Boring. But
that's what you get from a failed governor New
Jersey who left office with a 7% approval rating
and then got run out in New Hampshire. This time
it won't be any different. Trump then posting
a Photoshopped picture of Chris Christie from
yesterday's town hall, Photoshopped to put Chris
Christie at a buffet with all sorts of different
foods in front of him. Look, I can't even identify
what these foods are. Looks like maybe some
kind of Italian-American food or something like
that. Hard to hard to actually see. So Trump just
basically using fat jokes against Chris Christie.
I continue to not understand how it is that Trump
isn't being called out for the fact that he makes
fun of other people's weight. But Trump is obese.
Trump is obese. Yes, he has figured out ways to
disguise it. And yes, Chris Christie is more
obese than Donald Trump. But remember, there's
this whole story where Trump claims to be six foot
three and £239, which quite literally puts him £1
away from technically being obese, according to
BMI. BMI is not a perfect measure by any means,
but it gives us some idea. But we know that that's
not true. We know that Trump isn't as tall as he
says. And it's very obvious that Trump is much
heavier than he claims to be. And if you even
adjust his height by an inch or his weight by a
pound, he becomes obese. If you look at pictures
of Trump next to Obama, they look to be roughly
the same height. We know Obama is only six one,
not six three at 239. That makes Trump obese. We
know that there are pictures of Trump with former
baseball player Alex Rodriguez. We know A-Rod is
six three and he looks way taller than Trump. And
so if we assume Trump is actually six one instead
of six three, unless Trump is £200 or under, he's
obese. And you look at Trump and it's very obvious
that he's not £40 lighter than he claims to be,
he's somewhere between ten and £30 heavier
than he claims to be. So I say all of this
to remind you that Trump is obese, but he makes
fun of Chris Christie's weight. And part of this
comes from the magical thinking that is not based
in reality that his followers fall for. Yeah,
Trump is right, Chris Christie's fat. So he
would be a bad president. But the guy you
support is also fat. Yeah, but that's different.
That's totally different. Or he's not actually
fat. He's not obese. Or they're lying about
this or they're lying about that. How does an
obese guy get away with making fun of everybody
else's weight? I don't understand it. And I'm
going to have one more clip about this because
there's actually another element to this story.